right now everyone has heard the news
russia invaded ukraine last thursday
february 24th since then the u.s and
countries around the globe have levied
sanctions on the russian people and the
russian government they have removed
them from the swift payment system and
they have stopped importing a lot of the
goods and services that russia has to
offer but these sanctions have hurt the
russian people a lot the ruble has
basically free fallen out of the sky it
has lost 30 to 40 percent of its value
since the invasion began it has lost
around 80 percent of its value since its
peak in 2008 and also if you calculate
inflation based off the value that the
rupa has lost over the last week or so
the inflation rate in russia is 60 to 70
percent but where does bitcoin and
crypto companies what is their role in
the sanctions that have levy down and
where can they not only help these
sanctions be imposed but also make sure
that bad actors are not moving around
and going around the sanctions that have
been imposed on the nation let's start
with crypto companies coinbase ceo brian
armstrong had a pretty good threat on
this matter he talked about the role
that crypto companies play in the
sanctions that have been levied against
russia by the united states and other
companies but also talked about crypto
in general the crypto companies they
have to follow us rules they have to
follow u.s laws no matter what currency
asset or service they are giving to
customers they have to follow these laws
so it doesn't matter if they're using
gold usd real estate or other
non-financial assets they have to abide
by the us's law and if the u.s is saying
that they cannot service those people
they cannot because they are based in
the united states but let's also talk
about crypto one of the tweets in his
thread reads that being said we do not
think there's a higher risk of russian
oligarchs using crypto to voice tensions
because it's an open ledger trying to
sneak lots of money through crypto would
be more traceable than using us dollars
cash art gold or other assets brian hit
it right on the head here why would the
russian government or bad actors in
russia try to use bitcoin a public
ledger asset that every transaction is
recorded on the blockchain why would
they use this technology to try to avoid
sanctions it's easily traceable and very
hard to move for them my personal take
on this matter is that russia and
bitcoin do not link very well together
in these times why would russia try to
put bitcoin and measure their reserves
in bitcoin it's a notoriously volatile
asset that has seen both price
appreciation and price depreciation very
very rapidly also bitcoin itself cannot
be sanctioned and cannot help be levied
to impose sanctions on either citizens
or governments in general that is not
the purpose of bitcoin bitcoin is an
open source public ledger where people
can transact cross-border payments
basically instantly and basically for
free hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time